Traffic engineering has three steps: measuring
the network to figure out the current
traffic loads, forming a model of
how configuration affects the underlying paths in
the network, and then ultimately reconfiguring
the network to exert control over how
the traffic flows through the network. An
operator might measure the topology and traffic,
feed the topology and traffic to a
what-if model that predicts what will happen under
various type of configuration changes, decide which
changes to affect on the network, and then,
ultimately, control the network behavior by readjusting
link weights. So in summary, we have measurement,
modeling and control. Each of these three components
requires a significant amount of heavy lifting to
make both practical and accurate in practice.
Intradomain traffic engineering attempts to solve an
optimization problem, where the input is the graph G, where R is the set
of routers, and L is the set of unidirectional links. Each link L also
has a fix capacity. Another input is the traffic matrix or offered traffic load,
where Mij represent the traffic load from router i to router j. The output
of the optimization problem is a set of link weights, where wl is the weight
on any unidirectional link l in the
network topology. Ultimately, the setting of these
link weights should result in a fraction of the traffic from i to j traversing
each link l, such that those fractions satisfy the network-wide
objective function. Defining an objective function is tricky. We could
talk about, for example, minimizing the maximum congested link in
the network, evenly splitting traffic loads across links, and so forth.